what is going on there reject nation we
are excited what do you know we're
really excited
we made it this has been the most random
journey for
anything i've ever covered here because
i've never done something where i'm like
oh man this is kind of disappointing too
wow i'm really looking forward to this
now you know it's really up and down
it's been a roller coaster but it's been
consistent lately so i hope that
consistency remains umbrella academy
penultimate episode of season three
thank you guys so much who have
committed to this journey with us
um i've seen the response in some areas
where people were not enthused that we
weren't enthused in the beginning so
they're like i'm not gonna watch you
guys anymore and those are the ones who
stuck around to see if our opinions
would change appreciate y'all
guys leave a like that'd be so
appreciated especially with the time is
coming out helps in the algorithm to
keep this getting recommended over time
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified for
and then finale reaction for this to go
up not sure when that's going up i just
don't want to get lost in the middle of
uploading stranger things videos and uh
full length watch along so you sync up
with the time code or over at our
patreon page for super sexy rejects
thank you to all who have joined our
patreon page thus far reaction
highlights a full-length watch alongs
included for some shows exclusively and
the prepper people thank you for helping
us edit these down and thank you for
aaron for uh making the time to come
here aaron's got a busy schedule too and
he really does like work around my
chaotic nature to
accommodate so thank you all right guys
let's get to it
[Music]
back to the moon season one luther
luther
i don't care
[Music]
wasn't like goofy in the first season
right no he's very serious yeah
it redefined it in season two yeah
[Music]
god this looks so boring crackling from
wrong but didn't we find out that he
sent him to the moon for no reason at
all yeah man i'd be so pissed
[Laughter]
wow years on the moon
it's like four years if i'm not missing
oh jesus
yeah that's what's that's sloan's boy
right there you could tell why he would
get married this woman loves me i'm here
[Music]
[Applause]
jennifer
oh
the real abigail
abigail said abigail hargraves maybe
said the real abigail who's the fake
abigail what's the mom's name grace
i got confused
i was worried i'm here
here don't panic
nobody should panic [__]
[Laughter]
classic defense mechanism pushing away
the people who care about you the most
just like dad you'd be surprised how
much love he has to give and also he's
got this whole plan to save the universe
done one and done come on battery oh ben
knows the truth
oh gosh terrible place to sleep
from the elevator to the kitchen we all
we're all thinking about it it's the
elephant in the room here buddy i wish
you well
happy it's not your birthday happy
wedding day my friend take care
that's creepy as hell i can't do this
without you
do we have a deal
with that
[Music]
lay your guests down right now i think
it's pogo that would be wild
[Laughter]
our life circumstances are very
different
and being the only sober person at the
wedding i had the unique opportunity
to witness your argument with allison
such a shame to see a family struggle so
weren't you giving a speech
is it a sexy question oh god i hope not
do you think you're being too hard on
dad
[Laughter]
i mean it can be a
nope i'm going there i had a complicated
relationship with dad all right my dad
the one i grew up with
he
lied to me this is a different heart
grace
you need to give them a chance
they're bacon okay i've been a really
shitty sister lately you know if you're
handing out apologies
victor should be top of the list no i
know i'm
i'm going to get to him i just uh
working my way up we're going
from she's got something else up her
sleeve i don't buy it
she seems sincere right now dad called a
meeting at noon today are you both gonna
come no we'll be there how does it hurt
to hear what he has to say
don't underestimate the damage that man
can do at a family meeting that is not
the same man i find it odd how clothed
he is given that they were just having
an intimate moment on their
well she
but she has a robe on he has like a full
full-on long-sleeving pants
i take it you know why i'm here
wow what a crazy shot yeah my future
self
told me very explicitly
not to save this world
you are an arrogant son of a [__]
aren't you
the past is as much a mystery as the
future you ruined your life once before
by not listening to me are you prepared
to do that again
oh
hard facts tell me what happened with
you in the buffalo suite last night who
were you talking to no one i was alone
no i doubt you were in any condition to
remember
we should go don't want to be late for
the meeting
god damn it
whoa
fasting it's the only building that's
not disturbed i'd love to get some type
of like toy creation of that just the
hotel obsidian on the rock yeah it'll be
cool
there is a portal in the universe
i built this hotel around it and on the
other side is the answer
oh i'm going to miss the show now
god damn it
you my children are all that stands
between us and oblivion
are we ready to go oh i say we vote this
isn't a democracy
dad's calling the shots i'm with victor
we vote
you're asking us to risk our lives i
think it's only fair you give us some
time to discuss it
you're going to die anyway
tyler risk it or [__] off and die you're
already going to die
as well give it a shot you said you
choose me well this is who i am i'm a
fighter just like you i only said that
because i thought you'd be nice to me if
you wanted nice you'd be with someone
else
facts
i am your least favorite sibling i
ruined your life okay no that's not it
will you just stop and listen please
i'm gonna kill you if this apocalypse
says claire and ray are gone but
hating you won't bring them back and my
pain doesn't give me permission to hurt
you
if she doesn't have something under her
sleeve where's this whole off-screen arc
we're seeing coming from if we stay here
we die but if we go through the portal
we could we could save the universe so
can we just put our past behind us and
move forward together
i love you i love you too
i'm like i'm thinking more like zelda
trying to manipulate them
that cold stare i don't like it was
hargraves talking to her
oh possibly
i feel like she's just trying to
manipulate them i don't trust her i saw
something last night that i was not
supposed to see diego and lila
yeah they do it on the stairs sometimes
[Laughter]
he was making some kind of deal before
you ask i don't know what the deal was
or who it was with is it the rumor
ability that she has it wasn't me or
sloane
we were
busy doing other things last night as
you were fully clothed when is the old
man ever been straight with us i don't
know he was pretty ruthless in our
performance reviews he always gave me
five stars really look i'm old enough to
trust my instinct
it's telling me this is a trap but what
is there to trap at this point if it's
not all gonna end anyway
oh god that's creepy as hell does not
freak you out the mannequins
oh god
she must be the one who made a deal with
horographs yeah
was she drinking i don't really recall i
don't yeah me neither
let's go save the bloody universe
all right well since she said yes
i will stay
or what how's that for nice you're not
banksy you're dumb bro look i want to
believe okay i really do i just can't
shape the feeling that we don't know
what we're getting ourselves into you're
gonna die anyway why not find out sloane
and i talked and we're out
[Music]
that leaves you number five
oh he wants to find out oh he definitely
wants i saw the future and it told me to
sit this one out
i would stay hmm this time we accept our
fate
ding five okay
you're all pathetic oh there she is i
failed you when you were young and i
have failed you now and in doing so
i have doomed the entire universe i just
realized this is the most present
hargraves have been like physically in
the entire series i'll be in the
courtyard
awaiting the end idiots
show them that you're an alien
diego you don't stand a chance at seeing
that kid if you don't go
hey
what's up dad
you're a remarkable man luther despite
what i put you through i hope that you
can forgive me will you forgive me son
wow oh cheers you're manipulating yeah
[Music]
yeah of course
you see his little finger in him
give getting the little finger i only
wish your self-actualization could have
come at a better time for the universe
wait i i don't understand
[Music]
the best way to bring a family together
is at a wedding
or a funeral oh
we tried the one
now it's time for the other
no no
what
i
wow
i am so shocked right now just as you
found love it is a terrible shame
[Music]
but don't worry
i'll be sure to look after her
oh
i knew we couldn't trust him
[Music]
oh
man
i did not think that was going to happen
i did not see that coming
oh wow
[Music]
what are you doing i was right totally
little cereal i'm chasing my steps why
the old man is hiding something
damn this is so good
[Laughter]
alison apologized to me last night she
was ready to go ten rounds with me at
the wedding and this morning it's all
family and dad and love i don't know
something must have happened last night
but i don't know what
it must have been allison yep
do we have a deal
um
oh god
if we attack first he would still be
alive
wow
we had a good run oh girl
that dude is so underused right such a
great actor he's barely used
i thought he was going to have a bigger
role in this show
exactly as planned exactly as planned
get in the tunnel wait what are you
doing you've done a fine job bringing me
back into the family folk you're just
more trouble than you're worth
sorry oh you look at it you're a
[__] i don't believe this
you're in more trouble than you're worth
oh
what's the point of training him and all
that because he can survive this
oh he's gonna try to kill himself to
avoid it
whoa
holy hell
damn
wow
oh
man
what and the title is white are the or
the oh god credits are white wow
what a shocker of an episode
so what it stopped
crazy
oh whoa
we're on our time we're about to watch
the very next one um but damn that was
if i feel like the guy that was one of
those were
i would love to talk forever about but i
just kind of want to hop into that yeah
i know i know i feel the same way but uh
yeah i guess it's all true our graves
this whole time he's the whole time he's
playing them
why would he bring i don't understand
what the point of ringing klaus of not
bringing klops was
i feel like there's still something we
don't know i feel like there was a there
was intent behind that i feel it seemed
like he was trying to train him to
up his skill so he could use him but
then ultimately he thought he still
wasn't good enough so it's still back to
how it was before for klaus or
or i could see
him by training him to use his ability
he
brought klaus to his side which made it
more likely for the others to trust him
because klaus of all people trusted him
yeah
that's
didn't really work that way but yeah
yeah yeah
i can't believe there's still a purpose
though i mean it deals with time travel
and we've seen characters die and come
back
hargraves was the first one to die and
he's back so
you know there's a way to bring luther
back
it's like yeah luther and sloane
ultimately i i understood them not this
deciding to go because
we don't believe that we'll win so
let's just stay behind and enjoy our
last like that made sense i don't think
diego's made sense to me i was like
you're gonna die anyway diego's was
kind of silly it was like dramas for
drama's sake for me yeah yeah so that's
because
i actually got where diego was coming
from
with
him saying like lily you stay i go
because i think what he was getting at
was that we could still win
but i might die on the mission but that
doesn't mean we'll lose
he could just be one of the casualties
on the mission
so
as long as she can live consider if the
mission is successful then good
but when you flip it i'm like it doesn't
make any sense now like the motivation
other than to stand to i don't know
unless you guys have an opinion that
uh could change that um
or that i could be i'll i'm receptive
i'm not gonna say i'm gonna change my
videos
uh because to me it was like well
now you're actively choosing not to
fight for the opportunity to see your
kid
possibly you know when i'm like nah this
this kind of kind of went against the
character for me unless it was just some
like it was just some way to try to
trick her to stay behind i don't know i
thought it was kind of stupid yeah um
and then allison up i told you right
from the get-go i was like i was like
nah don't trust her yeah i felt felt way
too rushed for me and i was like yeah
there has to be something up her sleeve
and lo and behold it was yeah and um i
just thought it was gonna be pogo
because he was so
little used in this season
it's only in like one episode
yeah it's uh yeah that's true pretty
much essentially just one episode but
allison makes the most sense she's kind
of been
the worst i mean he's just kind of been
observing but i love the way they've
been riding hard graves this season
because it has been a back and forth
they've been letting you in on like oh
there's some like this is oh this
harkers is worse yeah the way worse is
not up front and always is a full-blown
villain
and it's like
they think they're going in to save the
day the way he plays the manipulation is
so good the manipulation is solid
because even when he walks in the room
and is shocked i'm like oh god even
that's believable and we know the truth
yeah and like the the thing you said
about there's two things that bring
people together either a wedding or a
funeral
like did you like orchestrate this did
you know this was going to happen anyway
it's cool with it this whole time it's
plan b
it's plan b yeah i mean i hope luther
can come back in some way because he's
just so he's so fun and so likable and
such a sweetheart and yeah how they've
how they've really uh rewritten him and
and given the actor a lot of room to
play has really been enjoyable and i do
hope we get to continue to see him
because you know he's like he's got like
the big oof he's kind of the the heart
of the the show you know it's such a
tragedy
of you know he finally gets the
reconciliation he's been yearning for
his whole life
and now it's it just gets killed at the
hands of him and also like not knowing
his dad's an alien yeah oh my god
there's so much happening with this guy
at once yeah the moment he called him
son i was like oh no he's playing him
he's playing him hardcore because that
feeling was playing him but i think he
was going to kill him
that's what was surprised me was like i
didn't think a death was coming no not
at all
man what does he have in store like it's
crazy how we're this far along and i
still have no idea what the [__] gonna
happen
i have no idea what's happening in the
next episode yeah i'm very uh i'm i'm
i'm really looking forward to it though
what a journey man what a journey we've
we've gone through
thus far going into this finale from
being pretty underwhelmed with the first
episode to like being
as excited if not more excited than we
were going into the end of the last
season yeah
well it's just crazy because
i think
like because you pointed out while we
were watching this this is the most
we've seen hargraves involved with this
season
at
[Laughter]
hyper presence
um
yeah he's so involved and and they've
done such an amazing job at fleshing out
um
like i just i think i just think that's
like brilliant manipulation because it
has you going and even though they clue
you in like very overtly at
very overly it's double negative
screw it uh over it is super overt in
the way they clue you in with like
certain looks that he gives or certain
choices that he makes like they're
showing you like there's something up
his sleeve
he's he's got a hidden agenda he's got a
tactic here yet he's that he the the way
they don't write and direct him here is
so perfect to the point where
is what one thing i hate in movies and
shows
is when an actor is playing a lie and
when i'm like guys he's obviously like
you know it's like if he walked in that
room he's like oh my god we did bad
acting right like luther oh no it's like
guys come on pick up i i hate when
when when and when
actors are forced to like do bad lies
and what i'm like no because real liars
are so believable yeah
they feel super sincere yeah and like
you go from
seeing stuff like the flashback and
seeing how
he was he was the cruel hargraves that
we know him to be in that 2014 flashback
where the split between him and pogo to
him training klaus and us really wanting
him to be this good father to these
children that have always craved their
father's love and their father's
attention and him continuing to play
that role to the other members of the
umbrella academy it's
yeah man he this actor and the way he's
written has really been really been a
journey and really been something to to
behold i love how he's worse yeah
like on a writing standpoint i'm like
damn they made them worse in a way that
doesn't mean
it's like cruel in a more sneaky way
yeah
that's i think that's scarier because at
least when the the original hargraves
like they all kind of knew
where they stood they knew they would
never get their father's approval but
him trying to to play on that fact of
the alternate hard graves not giving
them that attention to get what he wants
is so much more sinister yeah because
you still get the sense that he still
cared about his children yeah even
though he it was that kind of
like only tough love kind of dad
like so extremely only tough love
uh to the point where but but that
didn't mean he didn't care he always got
that sense he still kind of cared
um
but here you're like no this guy's this
guy's the devil yeah
i think the only question i had while
watching this that this left me with is
the fact that we see back in night like
the 1940s and 1918 that hargraves
discovers this portal and he he had his
wife on the moon who we resume is his
wife
um at this point but
we see that
and we know the original hargraves had
these very same plans but yet that
version of him killed himself
so why would he what happened for him to
abandon
uh this plan that he's had to
one day utilize this portal and i don't
know if the finale would give us that
answer or if it's just like an
inconsistency thing but i'm really
hoping that it does because they just
think it's fascinating i think
looking back from the first season
through this season
and
the seed of hargraves being the thing
that both tore them apart and brought
them back together through where we are
now i think it's gonna make for a
fascinating watch for anybody that's
going through the entire series it's
like oh it's like
each season has their own thing their
own kind of
doomsday thing they have to get to by
the end of the season but i think
overall watching the relationship
between
this father and these these broken
children is really going to be something
that's going to be fascinating to watch
both
as a
a plot unfolding and from like a
character study perspective
yeah
so why why does that have to be seven
like repopulating on a different
i mean i don't know i think because
you know each both
versions of the team
had seven like why did he pick seven
children to begin with maybe that's
he knew you know yeah he says it has to
be seven
i mean seven is an often symbolic number
so yeah lucky number that's why seven
yeah
but no he picked seven children seven is
uh like creation maybe he picked seven
children out of the 43
because he knew that one day seven would
need to go
to hotel oblivion
he picked the seven kids that he felt
would be the best for this job
that's true why is it always seven
because seven is you is it like a very
biblical number yeah that's what i'm
thinking of like the earth was created
seven days that's why i was thinking of
like recreational repopulation i don't
know we'll find out hopefully we find
out
there's lots lots to unpack and and then
for klaus to have such a tragic
because he he cared about the most and
also i i you know we we um
upgraded netflix to 4k
so i was like looking at these visuals
like damn those are crazy
that looks so good
yeah
it's really crisp and the visual
backdrop because you know this is the
first time they get a witness the
apocalypse slowly happen around them and
i just think it's been gorgeous but no i
mean we gotta watch the next one i don't
know when that reaction is going up but
uh for the next one but we'll try to get
to you as soon as possible
thing is going to be taking up a lot of
time right now
but guys keep a lookout so please do
subscribe and click that bell
uh all right we'll see you soon